[Musique]
il
dans ce vip on va parler aujourd'hui de
cyclisme sur piste
portrait 210 clair la plaisir oise 110
clair vous êtes en équipe de france et
use est également sélectionnée pour les
championnats du monde dans quelques
semaines oui parce que vous êtes
forcément satisfaite
oui bien sûr c'était un objectif de deux
saisons on arrive sur la dernière
compétition de la saison après une
grosse saison internationale cet hiver
donc forcément très contente de faire
partie de cette sélection
alors pourquoi vous avez commencé le
cyclisme très jeune alors c'est grâce à
mon papa qui faisait du cyclisme sur
route en amateur donc je suivais tous
les week-ends sur les courses et voilà
j'ai voulu faire comme comme le papa est
comme mon frère aussi qui a commencé à
faire du vélo très jeune donc voila
depuis l'âge de 5 ans sur le vélo et je
fais en club donc après j'ai commencé à
faire du vélo avant mais depuis l'âge de
5 ans au club
et forcément c'est une vocation oui bah
oui c'est une passion c'est depuis tout
petit je dis c'est un peu comme obélix
ce qui est tombé dans la marmite quand
il était petit moi c'est un peu la même
votre premier vélo c'était quand mon
premier vélo c'était je pense que
c'était à trois ans j'ai dû faire il
était jeune jeanne filloux d'ailleurs je
me souviendrai 3-1 alors comment votre
entourage a forcément bien réagi quand
vous l'avez annoncé oubliettes cycliste
professionnel
ben non pas pourtant pas forcément fin
en fait j'ai jamais réellement voulu
être cycliste professionnel ça c'est
fait
au fil du temps comme ça par contre
voilà quand j'ai voulu faire du vélo en
club mes parents voulaient pas forcément
parce qu'il savait que c'était des
grosses contraintes quand même
le cyclisme et puis bon finalement ils
ont cédé et voilà aujourd'hui je suis là
ils sont très fiers
vous avez commencé sur route ou sur la
piste alors quand on est petit si c'est
un mélange de tout on a des jeux de
quilles et donc des jeux d'adressé de la
route du cyclo cross
on touche un peu à tout et puis après
quand on dit vers l'âge de 10-12 ans
touché à la piste donc moi j'ai la
chance d'habiter à côté d'une piste donc
du coup je suis arrivé quinze ans voilà
si j'avais pas habiter à côté d'une
piste je serais pas là aujourd'hui
mais du coup là je suis arrivé un petit
peu comme ça et puis en voyant que
j'avais des qualités va forcément je
suis très compétitrices donc les j'aime
gagner et j'ai toujours voulu avoir plus
que ce que j'avais donc c'est ce qui m'a
amené ici
forcément la piste pourquoi pas la route
alors parce que ma la route c'est pas
non je préfère les efforts courts et
intenses
voilà j'ai toujours dit la route quand
on fait 50 km à l'est soirée est fatigué
il faut se taper les 50 au retour alors
que la piste on peut s'arrêter de suite
alors vous avez remporté votre premier
titre lors du championnat de france de
vitesse junior en 2005 où dansent ou
mais oui bien sûr oui c'était un j eunes
c'était je me souviens de mes
concurrents mais y'avait virginie cueff
et il y à vélo dit henriette aussi à
cette époque là et voilà on était tout
jeune un peu insouciante
mais non c'était des très bons souvenirs
vraiment c'était à la fois voilà on
aller à l'entraînement pour la
performance mais aussi on s'amusait bien
elodie henriette qui s'entraînait tous
les jours avec moi c'était ma meilleure
amie et j'ai toujours des contacts avec
elle d'ailleurs et mais vraiment voilà
c'était on était un peu je dirais pas
tant une colline vacances puisqu'on
travaille on était sérieuse mais on
rigolait beaucoup et c'était un déclic
ou pas pour vous ces championnats
ben en fait est ce que ça va donner
confortés peut-être dans l'idée d'être
cyclistes
comme je vous ai dit j'avais je m'étais
jamais dit je veux être cycliste
professionnel c'est juste que voilà
j'aime la victoire et que cette victoire
je me suis dis bien les prochaines faut
que je regagne il a déjà pris encore et
encore et encore et il faut que je batte
les filles qui sont plus vieille que moi
voilà c'était plus ça mon objectif qui
m'a amené aujourd'hui à être ici mais
c'était pas spécialement un rêve de de
me dire je veux absolument heidsieck et
professionnelle c'était plus gagné en
fait qui me tirer vers le haut vous avez
un esprit de vainqueur ce soir et voilà
je suis pas mauvaise perdante mais par
contre je n'aime pas perdre
justement si vous perdez est-ce qu'on
peut quand même vous parler après la
course il ya des moments où je préfère
d'abord être moi redescendre parce que
ça peut être la déception de la colère
après soi même parce que des fois on
peut faire des erreurs et perdu sur une
erreur
donc ça va dépendre de la compétition
maintenant
si quelqu'un était plus forte que moi ou
enfin je vais pas me trouver des excuses
parce que j'ai perdu
voilà c'est soit parce que j'ai fait une
erreur soit parce que j'étais moins
forte
vous êtes une bonne perdante voilà mais
après j'aime pas perdre alors chez les
juniors vous remportez vos premiers
titres internationaux
ouais avec notamment une médaille de
bronze aux championnats du monde 1500 m
oui parce que vous en souvenez également
heureux oui je m'en souviens aussi
restée à vienne donc soit commune plutôt
une bonne mémoire donc je me souviens
oui oui oui je me souviens même la
première c'est élise andré gwenaël la
deuxième c'était lyubov shulika qui
courent encore aujourd'hui et
non c'était vraiment
bon bon souvenir voilà au niveau mondial
on ne savait pas trop ce que ça pouvait
donner parce que quand on est junior on
connaît pas ses concurrentes
à l'heure actuelle je connais me
concurrence ça fait des années que je
suis sur le circuit mais quand on arrive
en juniors on sait pas du tout donc
c'était une bonne surprise mais après
bon je venais quand même pour gagner sa
lancée votre carrière
ouais on peut dire ça a lancé ma
carrière c'est vrai que c'est des
premières médailles internationales donc
on veut toujours en avoir plus derrière
c'était hors de question pour moi
d'arrêter après mes années gier vous
entrez du coup en équipe de france élite
ouais qu'est ce que ça fait quand on
arrive chez les élites abbas a fait une
claque dans la figure parce que le
niveau ans qu'il n'ya pas être
professionnel les élites c'est pas que
je voulais pas c'est que j'y pensais pas
réellement mais c'est vrai que voilà on
est en haut du tableau élite et puis au
final on se retrouve en milieu de
tableau voir en bas du tableau junior
pardon et on se retrouve en bas de
tableau en élite
donc ouais ça fait le niveau est quand
même
il ya une grosse grosse marche entre
entre les deux donc c'est là où il faut
avoir du mental et ne pas baisser les
bras parce que j'aurais très bien pu
dire c'est bon j'arrive pas j'arrête
donc voilà j'ai persévéré et puis en
2008 je ramène ma première médaille chez
les élites sur 500 m donc voilà j'ai pas
lâché l affaire j'ai mis deux trois ans
est arrivé j'ai su arriver
vous allez travailler mentalement aussi
à mentalement pas tout de suite à la
sortie des juniors ça c'était vraiment
plus
moi avec moi même mais sinon oui j'ai
actuellement je travaille avec une
psychologue meriam salmi qui m'aide
beaucoup
je travaille aussi avec des préparateurs
mentaux il ya des années en arrière
donc voilà c'est vrai que c'est très
très important moi je pense que c'est
très important c'est ce qui peut faire
la différence un petit détail qui peut
faire la différence et voilà gagner d'un
millième au lieu de perdre 20 millièmes
c'est indispensable peut-être d'avoir
des soutiens on va dire psychologie
bientôt long d'une carrière notamment
quand on est en équipe de france au plus
haut niveau
oui bien sûr après je plaçais
d'exposition médiatique forcément grande
que quand on est et puis enfin c'est pas
une jambe en juniors pareil sera fait
oui mais après c'est pas forcément que
par rapport aux médias c'est vraiment
aux résultats le mental fait quand même
je ne pourrais pas vous dire le
pourcentage mais un énorme pourcentage
de par rapport aux résultats
si on est très fort physiquement mais
qu'on n'a pas de mental c'est très
compliqué de gagner et inversement on
peut avoir un petit peu moins de qualité
est par contre un gros mental et
et tout exploser donc c'est vrai que
c'est très important ce côté là est très
important on oublie souvent mais voilà
il faut aussi savoir se relever des
défaites et en général on a quand même
plus de défaites que de victoires dans
dans une carrière sportive
et si on n'arrive pas à se relever d'une
défaite c'est très compliqué pour la
suite quoi cette première sélection en
équipe de france on l'avait vécu comment
vous l'avez appris ou a par contre ça je
vous avoue que je me souviens pas
comment je l'avais appris j'étais au
pôle france à hier donc j'imagine que
c'est mon entraîneur qui avait dû me le
dire honnêtement ça je me souviens plus
après voilà vous avez ressenti au bas de
la joie forcément la joie après c'était
un petit peu comment vous dire la
logique la suite puisque je m'entraînais
pour ça j'avais été championne de france
donc voila c'était un peu la la suite
logique et et voilà et puis cette
sélection je les ai vécu un peu c'était
c'était super marrant un peu comme une
colonie de vacances encore une fois
voilà ça veut pas dire je dis qu une
vacance à ne pas dire qu'on faisait
n'importe quoi mais toujours en train de
rigoler des super bons souvenirs en fin
de j'ai des souvenirs qui me reviennent
en tête du coup voilà c'était vraiment
vraiment génial et
et voilà et au final on a perfé donc un
mois mais les les copains copines aussi
donc c'est qu'on était vraiment dans une
bonne ambiance et c'est ce qu'il faut je
pense dans votre carrière il ya
également les jeux olympiques de
participer aux jeux olympiques de
londres en 2012 et de rio en 2016
qu'est ce que ça fait de participer à
des jeux olympiques et 20 je pense que
sur le coup on s'en rend pas forcément
compte parce qu enfin c'est pas que s'en
rend pas compte mais encore une fois
voilà c'était j'étais championne de
france je voulais aller au choix de
robes j'y suis allé je voulais chopin du
monde j'y suis allé je voulais aller au
jeu j'y suis allé voilà c'était la suite
logique de ma carrière
après voilà vraiment super contente
grosse étape de votre carrière la plus
grosse étape voilà mais comme j'en ai
jamais assez bas je voulais pas juste y
aller je voulais ramener médaille bon
ben ça fait deux fois deux fois je
ramène pas donc là c'est pour ça je
repars pour une troisième fois
exactement donc voilà c'est à chaque
fois aller le plus loin possible
et voilà mon but c'est vraiment à chaque
fois dans une tête sur les podiums tout
le temps on vous a vu notamment lors de
la cérémonie d'ouverture en 2016 premier
rang la délégation française qu'est ce
que ça fait de défiler devant tout ce
monde le monde entier finalement c'était
une joie une fierté aussi d'être d'être
là d'être dans cette équipe de france
vraiment en plus les jeux c'est très
particulier parce que c'est tous les
sports qui se regroupe on se connaît pas
mais on est très soudés
même si on se connaît pas ça c'est
vraiment je les ressentis à londres je
l' ai ressenti à un rio c'est vraiment
tout le monde est là tout le monde ce
soutien même si l'on connaît pas les
autres sa tête parce qu'on est tellement
que forcément ne pas connaître tout le
monde et c'est vraiment ça fait beaucoup
de bien et on est une équipe de france
vraiment on peut dire que ça c'est une
équipe de france c'est très très fort
après voilà une fois qu'on est au jeu
faut pas oublier qu'on n'est pas là
touristes olympique comme disait un
ancien entraîneur mais voilà c'est
vraiment il faut rester concentré parce
que c'est tellement particulier qu'on
peut vite se perdre aussi dans les jeux
pan dans l'ambiance des jeux tout ça
mais voilà le fort mentalement comme on
le disait tout à l'heure
aussi oui de pas se disperser 2
faut vraiment rester concentré sur sur
la compétition alors en 2012 vous
terminé 6e de la vitesse par équipes
même place à rio en 2016 avec jinni
aussi à virgin également chef
alors vous avez des regrets ou est-ce
que c'était une expérience positive
malgré tout alors à londres j'ai quand
même des regrets parce que voilà j'étais
pas je mettais pas qualifié en
individuel j'étais pas très très bien 2
de m'être qualifié entre guillemets que
avec l'équipe et du coup oui je peux
avoir des regrets sur sa de peut-être à
ce moment là ne pas avoir été assez
forte pour me dire 110 quand même tu
fais les jeux tu fais qu'une épreuve
mais voilà donc voilà j'ai pas fait une
super belle perf à londres
médaille était envisageable non je pense
que c'était pas envie d'un foie que non
je pense pas mais mais quand la paire
fallait pas là
c'est toujours plus compliqué quoi
j'aurais préféré faire sixième avec une
perf plutôt que sixième sens perf
évidemment et puis après à rio voilà
j'avais passé quatre ans avant un peu
compliqué donc j'étais très contente
forcément de faire les jeux puisque ce
n'était pas gagné d'avancé du tout on
s'était qualifié vraiment pour 3 points
donc pour vraiment un tout petit poil
quoi mais voilà après c'est riou c'était
un petit peu plus compliqué j'étais
moins en forme par rapport au passé
enfin à ses quatre ans de galère cash
quelle sera la suite pour vous sandie
clair de nouveau zizou ainsi je crois je
vois là pour aller au jeu après jeu pour
l'instant on est dans les quotas mais il
reste encore un an de qualification donc
rien n'est joué d'avancé il va falloir
vraiment que on lâche pas la faire et
qu'on continue à travailler dur et puis
vraiment moi je la veux cette médaille
olympique coi donc j'ai pas envie de
refaire 6e lui-même quatrième mois je
vais toujours claude yom voilà après le
sport on ne peut pas savoir ce qui se
passera merci beaucoup
sandie clair est à bientôt et bon
courage pour les championnats du monde
qui se dérouleront en pologne merci
beaucoup
[Musique]